today we're going to unravel a mystery
that has intrigued us all the identity
behind the Twitter account at aging. one
a Twitter account that shares different
media whether it's Publications or news
articles or even sometimes my videos
around the field of Aging
research with a secondary mission of
advancing public awareness of the value
of jury science and health band
promoting research and its translation I
hope you enjoyed this fun episode hey
hey fellow Shiki
scientists hi David or aging talk one I
should say welcome yes I'm imagining
with your uh uh prowess with your
illustrations like you're taking
illustration just like taking a mask off
me it's like aha having some kind of a
face there yes You' finally been reved
great to be here I'm I'm a huge fan of
your work I think you do your incredible
credit to the responsible science
communication and it's also just a lot
of fun so I think it's getting a lot of
people interested in both geroscience
specifically and also more broadly the
biological sciences and research and
Health Sciences so kudos to you it's
it's your like there's a generation that
will remember the Shiki chent show and
hopefully multiple Generations so
interested in continuing then thank you
so much and also I mean thank thanks for
the platform you've created on Twitter
as well I mean a lot of the times the
videos I create have come from papers
that I've seen you share on Twitter so
goes both ways and also you've been a
massive promoter of my my work on
Twitter which has also helped my
platform to grow not an official
promoter Elenor never asked me to just
for the record we have no no no uh
relationship and this is actually my
first time meeting Elanor on camera and
Elanor doesn't even know my name yet she
knows my face which she just picked up
literally moments ago she saw my face
and uh now now you are too and I'm only
going to release she's only going to
release this video after the big the big
announcement and I can give some
explanation about that you maybe exactly
so I feel like myself and the rest of my
audience are probably going to have the
same first question which is who exactly
are you okay I'm actually going to start
by revealing my name and I I very you
know I I put some thought into
everything I do so deliberately Elanor I
didn't reveal my name until so they're
literally live live the name uh so the
questions are broader uh and basically
my name is the hybrid of two different
famous geros scientists there's David
Sinclair everybody knows and everybody
knows near bareli too and I Am David
barsel no relation to either um although
um yeah they they're both uh uh you know
it's I'm I'm honored that they're both
uh at least as the Timeless film filming
followers of my uh my my station but uh
it's uh yeah so I'm David baray that's
the short version but who is David
baray should I elaborate of course yes
okay okay um so basically I first got
interested in the the in science from a
very young age I I love like math and
science were my favorite subjects I
totally geeked out of them I would just
spend hours on the stacks of the the the
library and I would enjoy like studying
nature outside and things like that and
then sometime later I would say by the
time I got to high school I was middle
school high school I was thinking like
what am I going to do what am I going to
do for a career and basically I thought
I love helping the world I read uh still
the most influential book in my life to
date is stepen Cy Seven Habits of Highly
Effective People because um I my
greatest passion is kind of
self-improvement and finding ways to do
cool things in the world that that help
people and um the the science and
biological sciences are my other passion
I thought hey maybe as a doctor I could
do both like I would always be applying
science and be challenged and then I
would be able to help people one-on-one
which is always I enjoy that one-on-one
thing like like in large groups I'm like
I'm a total introvert I'm like in the
corner I'm guy in the party it's like
like watching Everybody Dance meally at
least historically I've had a little bit
of uh Renaissance over the decades which
is a whole another story but uh
basically I volunteered uh in a um in
emergency room and I thought that was
cool and I also had really bad asthma
that was another influence for me that I
I thought a lot of doctors ironically is
I thought a lot of doctors were really
terrible and I thought I should be able
to do better than this like just I mean
they were I God blessed them I'm so
grateful to modern medicine and there
were so many great doctors that I met
but I I guess I just mean as a patient
the patient experience really stunk like
in e in the middle of the room being
rushed to an emergency room and like no
control over the flow of a visit what's
happening and not knowing what's
happening and not being able to
effectively ask questions so uh those
things like but I realized how important
medicine was to literally saving my life
because I had really severe asthma so
all those things brought me to decide on
medicine which in turn uh made me apply
to a particular College the University
of Rochester that subscribed very much
to the biopsychosocial medical model and
that's basically one where hey you know
what the science is great the flexner
report and this wh whon sha this High
Precision rigorous science that's
Laboratory based on one side on the
other hand biopsychosocial medicine says
we're also embedded in a social fabric
where the community and our
relationships and uh the our our
psychology all these things leads to
contribute to health and and uh that and
social medicine so all those things made
me think ufr would be compatible and
that led me to go to college my next
step so I'm trying to pause here Shiki
is uh I I sort of reviewed my history
before before this and it's kind of a
weird thing someone who's like very much
a studier like super duper type a super
analyst and I'm like going through the
archives because I keep everything I
don't throw anything out like I was
Finding like back in college I was
already uh interested in caloric
restriction I wrote to Richard Windrock
one of the pioneers of caloric
restriction this is an email I saved
from
1996 so yeah I mean I I did the this was
like in early days I actually helped um
bring the uh internet to my school in
1993 in high school uh which uh in high
school like there wasn't a there was
very primitive web it was like Ark uh
Veronica gopher all these weird
protocols that nobody knows anything
anything about anymore and 1 1200 bod
modm is
going
connecting and and like I was think so
um anyway I wanted to transition to
college where basically in between I
wasn't yet sure I thought I was Premed
but I really loved Science and
Technology what my helping the teachers
like uh use the internet to communicate
with other schools which was all like
text based what we were doing that led
me to be in a small panel the global
classroom youth panel for the world
future Society so in this great futurist
society meeting I was one of a few high
school students almost read uh met
alore uh there he had to cancel last
minut but it was a surprise because you
know people like him don't announce
they'll just kind of show up or not um
but he he he ended up doing something
else and writing to us but uh so anyway
that that led up to college I'll pause
here okay wow and so uh you obviously
had a lot of interest in different areas
of Science and so um when you were doing
the medicine uh studies was there
specific parts that you found more
interesting than others or did you
specialize at any point okay so um the
basically when I was in college I wasn't
which was like the next stage of my
degree I got all my degrees are in twos
I have two bachelor's degrees I have two
master's degrees I have two doctorates
and I have two board certifications one
of them is kind of a pseudo board
certification uh but I'll I'll answer
your question first and then perhaps uh
unpack College a little bit okay um so
long story short I'm actually I don't
practice longevity medicine as a
physician though one of the reasons that
I'm I'm coming out publicly in a desire
to make more impact is I thought it'd be
really cool if I could be a health coach
consultant in the area of longevity
medicine without actually writing
prescriptions or or anything like that
so it wouldn't be under my medical
license but just more like uh um you
know my wife has this joke sometimes
that we go to places and health comes up
and then more and more people demon an
interest because I give detailed answers
and she says I should just do an start a
show called ask Dave or something so I
thought to myself I do enjoy that and um
wouldn't it be cool if I you know I had
in addition to what I practice in that I
am able to coach and consult in the area
of longevity without actually you know
writing prescriptions or giving an
official medical advice but rather as an
expert uh colleague and as a life life
coach too way I I enjoy just helping
people in general anyway so uh in answer
to your question I'm a I'm actually a
board certified
dermatologist and one of the nice things
about about Dermatology is is that um I
find it fun that you could just walk
into a room and the other doctors didn't
know what it is nobody knows what it is
you take one look and you know the
diagnosis you just see it that pattern
recognition is cool I also like that I
could treat people a very diverse
population you know men as well as women
older as well as younger I also I've
always had very eclectic intellectual
interests like all over the place and I
like taking deep dive and if I chose for
example to be a surgeon or even internal
medicine you're a little out of oh there
okay um I don't know if it's my camera
yours um that's my dermatologist detail
orientation
fix anyway so
um what I liked is that there was a good
work life balance too it's a stable job
extremely high demand when I applied I
don't know how it is now but it was it
was definitely the top three maybe the
number one most competitive sub special
specialy to get into and one reason for
that is uh not just the skin is an
amazing organ it's largest organ in the
body although that's kind of been drawn
into question a lot of people go into it
just because for the simple fact is if
you want to have a balance between uh
personal life and your work or just
different interests then Dermatology
lends itself much better to work life
balance and um in the I work part-time
as a
dermatologist for comp complex reasons
but part of it is this it's like part of
it is like my family they give me more
time for my family because I have uh we
have a wonderful son who is uh twice
exceptional so he's absolutely brilliant
like Mena is the top 3% of IQ and he got
tested and he's a Davidson scholar which
puts him in the top tenth of 1% in
IQ uh so uh he's really really bright
and the other exceptional is he's
neurode Divergent he just kind of thinks
different ly and you know we all matured
he's he's 17 now and I'm sure he's going
to listen to this one day so Adam I love
you and and I love your your
neurodiversity um and uh sometimes
school systems don't perfectly align
with with people who are uh diverse in
the way they think and so that takes
some time also and I also uh chose to
work part time so I could pursue my own
learning and helping my family and this
personal Pro project and my own sense of
life being very finite and at my age
there's so much I want to conquer this
lifetime so um so anyway that's
Dermatology elanar an answer to your
question and the other uh board
certification they board people who are
already practicing Physicians for
something that's called lifestyle
medicine so it's a an exam I I I
prepared for they had a curriculum and I
studied and different specialties can
sit for it and I I I sat for and passed
their exam in Florida so I'm also
licensed by the American Board of
Lifestyle medicine I so I'm a diplomat
of the American Board of Lifestyle
medicine which is things like you know
getting good sleep reducing stress
exercise diet all these things which are
like the other non biogerontology
geroscience things that I tend to focus
on your General Health span uh but I
don't do that medically I just apply to
my family I pursued this and that was
something else that lend myself to you
know I'm so confining myself by being
anonymous if I did coaching and
Consulting maybe I can help some people
because there I I go so deep in those
areas and I have you know certified it
and I'm just not using in it and sitting
on it so that's kind of like the the
medicine track uh but I'll pause here
for your your your your questions um
before going back taking a step back
probably to college I'm thinking yeah I
mean FY that's super impressive um I'm
intrigued that you've got such the the
lifestyle um was that say that was more
recently that you acquired um that
boards membership yes I uh more recent
things I've gone uh which I can cover
more later are uh in NBA um very proud
that someone who was not for like I I
studied the on my own I read the
certified financial planning their
official textbook for one of their exams
and I read almost every section of their
textbook except for a few areas like
estate planning or certain business
entities so I love reading textbooks
anyway so I I'm kind of a serial degree
getter even if I don't plan on using the
degree directly just if I find it cool
and fun and potentially applicable like
I was the first physician in my family
unless you count a a distant family
relative like my
grandfather's cousin uh was one of the
two awardees of the Nobel Prize and and
Physiology and Medicine in 1922 Odo Myer
Huff but he's really remote um and so I
have this huge debt and I had no and I
was just starting I was like gee I maybe
I should know more about finances so
that then I did all this reading on the
cfp stuff and then after I felt like I I
mastered the like Certified Financial
Planning type stuff for Life fin thought
but wouldn't MBA useful because at the
time I was one of the uh Partners in a
large group practice I was uh working
fulltime and we rotated in and out of uh
managing the partnership and I thought
an NBA would be useful for that too so I
built on on some of the skills like
learning time value of money projections
uh to much more globally like running a
business and I did that from um UMass
ammer uh they had a hybrid program so
that's just an example so that's another
example of a more recent degree after my
medical degree another is an MS in in
Psychology um the MBA I was proud though
I I I got the the both their award
societies whatever their names are and I
a 4.0 GPO GPA excuse me I I can I get a
4.0 GPA but apparently I can't uh get
the acronym for grade point average
right um but but um so yeah I've always
loved to learn Elanor and that's what
led to a lot of these these uh
Adventures including the the college
which I can take us to when oh great I
mean I definitely shared that uh passion
for learning always trying to read as
much as I can and I'm actually somewhat
jealous of the fact you've had the
chance to do with these different
degrees so have we covered all of them
well I think the the bachelor's degrees
are actually relevant I thought it would
be fun like for the for The Bachelor so
I said I get everything everything into
I have this left side of my brain that's
very logical and this right side that's
very expansive and creative and um and
they've always kind of been at war with
one another but sometimes creating
harmony with one another so to satisfy
that in college I got a ba in health and
society which is extremely broad it was
highly influenced by my adviser Ted
Brown who ended up becoming chairman of
the Department of history and Medicine
and in the division of um and also he
had an affiliation with the medical
school in the division of of the medical
Humanities and health in society is like
everything it's like public health it's
like medical sociology ethics in
medicine it's uh anthropology of
medicine it's like Health policy about
uh Public Health you name it everything
like Health it's like population health
and so it's cool it's very broad picture
like how to help General
populations um so that's that and the
the other de the degree I got was a BS
and and cell and developmental biology
so I wanted to do more than just a ba
which was broad but to really specialize
in cell and development biology gave me
a broad background but let me really
specialize it was hard because it wasn't
just you can apparently get overlapping
courses if it's called getting a double
major but doing a double degree is
different that means they don't allow
the same amount of overlap they make it
harder for some re because you're
officially they get reimbursed less it's
something weird like they're giving me
two official certificates instead of a
joint one so anyway so um that was a lot
of fun and actually some of my hardest
working years were were in in in college
I I graduated um uh summa kumla 5 beta
cap 3.92 GPA which I'm very proud of
because I in some ways more than some of
the other CU I worked so hard I was
pread I was was doing everything
um anyway but that's where I met my my
my wife which which was a whole other
left and right brain thing which
probably would make it more a little
colorful if I added that to the
narrative if that fits of course yeah I
mean uh I think I mean I've look back
fondly on my undergrad days and realized
how hard I actually work then and I know
I still do work hard but I don't think
it quite matches the intensity you get
when you find a subject that you really
want to love Le about it was crazy it's
double it's it's like I'm a
perfectionist I'm like detail oriented
and then on top of that I was sort of
obsessed with getting into medical
school it's funny like um there's
someone famous on Twitter has more more
followers than me he has no idea that he
was my TA in
1993 harit Malik nicest smartest ta I
ever met he was only like like a year or
two older than was a graduate student
and I must have seemed like such a nut
case to him because I they required like
one teaching session to go to but me
being obsessive I went to to both of
them and I was the one that sat front I
raised my hand it was fun at graduation
because I had no idea that I kind of
became pseudo famous in some of the
Premed classes like I was an introvert I
didn't talk to anyone so but it would
always be the front center like raise my
head ask ask a question uh and uh for
better or worse but um anyway so
um in terms of the left and the right
brain and the connection to to my wife
uh the and um it's interesting because
in college it's really where my first
exposure was to geroscience I mentioned
I I wrote to Richard wiro with the
caloric restriction but actually this is
a good segue also to
um meeting my wife because I think
there's a quote that that's appropriate
to meeting my wife that is slightly
entertaining that relates also to
geroscience okay so
um I was pulled like uh the campus there
was campus times our newspaper and they
actually had a kind of geroscience
longevity themed question the question
was if you could be reincarnated is
whatever you want what would you be and
they had like six people and I was like
o this is a little bit after I met her
and this says David bars life take five
skull I didn't mention like I one of the
harder things in college was combining
two programs one was to have a tuition
free fifth year that the college pays
for for another area of Education
another was to get like an honors the
thesis so one was called take five and
the other was called senior Scholars so
I met with both heads and I was the
first person to like Envision combining
the two so I did an honors thesis and
Health Care policy for my tuition free
fifth year plus it gave me extra time
for getting you know getting to know my
soon wife to be I was she was my first
and was always will be my first and uh
so what I wrote to her being the corny
person that I am so the question is if
you could be reincarnated as whatever
you want what would you be and I wrote
myself because outside um because I
consider myself if the lighting isn't
great here U because I consider myself
the luckiest man in the world to to know
to know such a perfect girlfriend or
have such a perfect girlfriend so that's
what I wrote and that this is what I
look like in 1993 above this here yeah
very different hair you can
see wow anyway um so the story actually
and at the and I was very much into
longevity then it wasn't just CR but I
did kind of practice many CR then which
later during a later stage it's a whole
story we won't have time for where I did
like real hardcore CR practitioner
myself and I only practice CR light
these days for a variety of complex
reasons that I feel are optimized but at
the time I read Jee carper's uh uh fight
aging or something like that um uh fight
aging now or stop aging now and um that
was influential but my wife what uh I
noticed her in the dining Center Long
long before I met her Kathy is her name
U and I noticed there's this woman she
had this be
beautiful uh big Italian eyes but what
really caught my attention is she was
always laughing and she had this big
smile and she was laughing and she was
like egar and like my social opposite
she was like a real social butterfly and
she'd always be in that dining Center
other table and she also wore glasses so
I thought you know to stereotype I you
know maybe she's she's smart like I like
you know like intelligent the too more
most attractive quality to me in in in
individuals then and and now are their
their intelligence and their character
and um so basically I said to myself at
the time if I ever have the opportunity
I I have to meet this woman I have to
meet her and I think to myself um you
know and this was at a time I said to
myself I was past the stage where I was
like I can't date I'm not doing anything
I worked so hard that I literally
exasperated a colleague who in a a
friend who constantly invited me to
parties Friday night and every time I
like I'm sorry I have a study an exam on
Monday and I can't study it says it's
Friday night and this say feel free to
cut it if it's not not like appropriate
but I I I I said it in in good spirit
because he he had friends like this but
finally one day he was so frustrated he
was like what's the matter with you
what's all the matter with you you study
harder than my Indian friends or
something so it's like the weirdest
compliment that I ever got was was that
uh but anyway back to my my wife so I
said to my that was now at a point where
I was a well enough track that I knew I
would do well and I would as well as I
can predict past the bars to get into
medical school that I said to myself
okay if I meet this this this young lady
I got to do it but I have a big problem
I've never dated anyone I'm a total
social introvert how the heck am I going
to do this so then I came up with a a
secret plot this is my secret plot okay
so I'm a very determined individual like
before we had a Neo from the The Matrix
I'm imagining you're superimposing my
face with I am Neo with the glasses
scene that was such a powerful movie for
me because I literally when I was
studying I would study like for a double
digit hours timed if someone stopped to
talk to me I went to the bathroom I
would stop the watch and I would time oh
so I do like a good uh you know 12 plus
hours of studying
consistently um a day anyway so um I I
said to myself I Am David barsel so that
was kind of like I am Neo before the
movie I Am David vs I I am a machine so
I'm so determined I have to figure out a
way where an introvert who's very left
brain can do something very right brain
and I came up with a solution I even
thought about maybe writing a book about
it when day but this is the this is the
idea I came up with Elanor I said
okay the analysts and me will be good at
fing directions I just need to have the
right side of my brain give the left
side of my brain a task and if it if the
right side of the brain gives a task
even if it's a social one the left brain
says yes master I'll be an El I'll be
precise I will follow it to a tea so I
had my right brain say to myself I say
if you meet this woman again
okay if you meet Kathy or I didn't know
her name if you meet her you have to
talk to her assignment one and the
second assignment you have to at the end
of that conversation no matter how it
goes no matter how embarrassing it is no
matter how destined you are to failure
you have to ask for her phone number and
you know what you can feel good about
that because what's going to happen is
she's is she's going to say that's okay
or you know or like you know wh why
don't you know she's not going to give
me her number she's going to be polite
and say something like that why don't I
take your number and I'll be like okay
pressure's off and I'll be happy either
way so that's what I did and basically
it was at a wedding shower uh and I I
saw her across I was like oh my God
she's here I have to do this assignment
okay I say I am David bareli David barel
can do anything I am a machine I Am
David barel so I I do that to myself and
I so I walk up to her and it's funny
like I'm extremely like you can tell I'm
an intense guy so imagine I'm an intense
guy in a mission with the adrenaline so
I'm like you know what I mean like so I
walk up to her you know but I'm very
sincere people can usually tell that I'm
I'm a really like I'm a emotions on the
surface I'm very passionate but I'm very
on the surface I don't hide I I I am who
I am so we have this conversation that's
kind of exciting and gauge it kind of
goes okay and the end of f Elanor I I uh
basically
I it's that moment and I ask her for her
phone
number and as expected she didn't give
her phone number and she was like uh
said why don't I you know why don't I
take take your number and she did it so
such a nice graceful way it's
like first of all I'm like so like
already I'm so anomer with her already
and rather than feeling you know
rejected I think to myself oh and she's
got such a nice heart she doesn't want
to hurt my feelings she's you know she's
just making up an excuse so little did I
little did I know like uh
Apparently after that conversation we
had this we shared stories thereat she
was like thinking about me like uh so
what ended up happening is she left a
message on my my machine
and and my answering machine and to this
date I I had it recorded and I like
wrote down either that or another event
and I actually typed it up actually
typed The Chronicles of her meeting it
was like a 50-page document something
ridiculous like that of like the
chronicles of my my first relationship
unpublished and under lock and Seal
never to be seen by public but that's
just the type of person I am to so
anyway I documented what she wrote and
but she met me as a friend
and
uh long story short one of the things I
recorded is um I I was very surprised
that one day after I already was in
invited by one friend like a female
friend of mine to accompany her to the
vienes ball uh she left a message to say
like to invite me to the vienes ball so
then I had like a dilemma because I had
a friend that's female and I had this
woman that I was extremely enom rated
with with um so I asked permission from
the First first girl and I asked said
I'm in the who was a friend and it was
clear was a friendship I said I want to
show you a good time and I have these
feelings for this this other person I
wonder is it possible in some way that I
could go to the ball with both of you
but I would only do it with both of your
with with your permission and I would
tell her and she said she said sure So
that was
it was it was like it was like what
almost like one of those movies except
both knew about each other and I think I
kind of managed to show them both good
good times and have good times with both
of them but that's that's my The Saga
the you know my my Cathy my Kathy
stories and uh my left brain right brain
so and that was kind of kind of college
where it wrapped up where uh one of my
proudest moments in college was the
graduation ceremony for the ba and
health and syst Society where my my I'm
kind of more proud of the little
certificate from that than I am of
everything else cuz it had my name and
like in every almost every category like
honors thesis and like like uh highest
honors and you know different random
categories and I was very that that felt
really good and I've always been but I
want to make clear
it's making a difference that's really
the biggest driver but anyway feel cut
all that out that's that's I I love that
but but I just read the stuff again so
like I have all these images of myself
and college and you have this adventure
where you're discovering science you're
you're discovering yourself and now I'm
in a sort of re reemergence of that
because when I turned
49 I made a promise to myself say you
know what this year I'm going to do
something totally different like
symbolically it's like between now and
when I turn 50 so that secret project
project 49 ended up being like my God
people will discover my identity if I
decide to coach and consult the
longevity so I need to come out and if I
need to come out hey wait a minute if I
come out maybe I can make more of a
difference maybe I could be on a pod
podcast or maybe I could interview
people at a much more sophisticated
level than most of the science
communication out there with the
exception of Elanor Shiki you guys
better subscribe I do
anyway well yeah F thank you for sharing
all of that um it was lovely here and
also just to understand you better I
think it was very obvious to myself um
to have a better understanding of your
background and your personality and I
think um I hope my audience also
appreciate that and I now that you've
mentioned it a few times and I'll super
curious as to how uh the Twitter side
started and how your um aging talk one
began and how that fits in with your
timeline yes good question so in between
I got my PhD in health Services Research
um that was a fun time where I I I I
basically I I had the the privilege of
working with not one but several of
either committee members or close
advisers like Kurt stangy who ended up
being like head of a family medicine
Journal I was considering Family
Medicine at the time uh he was Institute
of medicine Duncan newuser was on my PhD
commit he was Institute of medicine and
like uh and like maybe maybe a third
I'll have but uh basically during my PhD
years I settled on on melanoma uh Health
Services Research and I I I like in just
a like coule only like two like only a
few years I got like maybe up to around
a dozen peer-reviewed Publications so I
was working like a very hard done um
working collaborating with different
people but one of the cool things about
that is i i t i got as while I was still
just a a uh medical school student in my
mdphd I developed a I started an
evidence-based medicine site I and I
taught evidence-based medicine to
dermatologists and and was kind of their
faculty as a medical student for the
Dermatology for those sessions where I
wrote the curriculum and delivered it so
that was really cool um but what so
that's all in the backdrop of I
mentioned already the lifestyle medicine
I'm giving the evidence-based medicine
background this context and within the
context of the PHD which was um we were
the first class to do the Dual degree
program and I got to meet the Surgeon
General at the time and had fun there
anyway I got to uh then I thought it
would be cool if in Twitter I could
apply some of what I have for my PhD and
interest in lifestyle medicine and I
could also apply some of the geroscience
where I've been personally obsessed with
uh long my personal longevity and health
span my whole my whole life uh like I
have very elaborate optimization
routines which are I don't discuss uh I
discuss really minimally um but uh
because it's a lot of it is pre-cutting
Edge it's not quite evidence-based
medicine it's more evidence-guided
medicine best bet medicine and always
evolving so I thought hey wouldn't it be
cool I have this extremely elaborate
Universe where I can dig so deep uh
Elanor in the literature some broader
view having not having a lab that I need
to supervise people and students and
grants and all these things and I can
devote 100% of that part-time effort to
just learning geroscience just learning
learning learning learning it's just
such a depth of knowledge that it just
seems silly that I just keep it for
myself and my family so I thought well
low-lying fruit is I'm doing these deep
literature searches for myself anyway uh
as someone very interested in the space
and I I can make an impact just by
bringing in knowledge in one space uh
for good debate and discussion and also
to reveal all the bad geroscience hype
and media out there to people who know
better so that though my role and I
don't have the the time and it would
conflict with other missions such as
inclusiveness to in in a broad number of
people debating And discussing so as
many people can come together not just
those who are more
evidence-based um that I'm able to um
basically put that all Under One Roof so
sorry to wind that up again I'm saying I
thought that I
could low-lying fruit is to bring all
that knowledge in one one one space
where people can know what's what's good
and what's bance out there and so that
people can have healthy uh debates and
bring in the science and for not to be
full of hype and for not to be like one
narrow research lab that focuses on the
stuff they're excited about and less
about the stuff they're less excited
about or even things that they might
have a conflict with and maybe a
conflict of interest with like uh for me
um when I did this and I was Anonymous I
had like no no conflicts because you can
even learn about me you know what I mean
like you I would shouldn't say no there
are always some because like to like to
for people to learn about it like maybe
ego or something like that for people to
learn about you or or you're making a
difference or whatever so I guess those
are kinds of conflicts but I didn't even
have anything to sell nobody could even
find me because they didn't know who I
was because some people say I have I
have no conflicts but they have a
service that they have that it C cost
not that that's bad you know and and now
I'm kind of in that in the role where
I'm doing coaching and Consulting for a
very small number of people so it's not
meant for your general view viewership
sorry only have a few hours a week so
it's it's kind of concierge type that
only is suitable for a few people out
there sorry but I won't give up I won't
aband the new Twitter people I I care
and I'm I'm not going to give in fact
this the coming out because of that
thing which is only applies to a tiny
segment of people lets me be public
which in turn means I can do even more
like to be on with with Elenor so that's
what brought me to that's what brought
me to to Twitter originally this idea if
I can make an impact in these ways wow
yeah and I think um with t itself I mean
obviously the platforms changed over
time and personally I didn't I think at
some points when I've been uh following
your Twitter feeds there was times where
I just assumed it was a bot with all
these papers coming out daily but
obviously that's not the not the case
but so how has your presence on Twitter
evolved over time did you find that your
style changed or like if you remember
the very early days when you originally
started the the account did it yeah how
was it changed over time that's a really
good question when I came to I off my
decision decisions in life are multi
multifactorial us usually when people
ask why you did X and they say did X
because of Y and I tend to think of
maybe because of my rigorous biostat
background or my my interest in
evidence-based medicine and clinical
decision making which has a
Quant background as does modeling which
I did a little bit of modeling in my PhD
too for one of my courses all those
things make me think in terms of a
multivariate uh equation in terms of all
the variables that go into making
decisions so
um how have so that multivaried equation
is always optimized towards doing good
and H
having having the most positive impact
while having the most fulfillment and
and and
positive in in you know my life
experience and sharing that with others
so that how that's optimized varies over
time so when I came on to Twitter part
of that polyvar equation what I describe
but I any every answer I give every
single answer I've given to something
you've asked me today and anything in
life it's like just one element of
something I I that I usually think about
more broadly so I thought about I could
learn new skills I enjoy learning new
skills these skills could be it could be
useful I I don't want to ever be
antiqued and if I'm a Believer and
Longevity that means being able to be a
contributor to society your entire
lifespan and free to and isn't it cool
to be able to grow and Thrive so part of
my goal was just to learn the platform
and as I learned the platform I was also
learning social media like it's like a
lot of crazy craziness out there a lot
of hype um something that I'm very proud
of that I have like very strong beliefs
at opposite ends of the spectrum are
follow me there are people who have
massive followers follow me and that are
opposite ends of the extreme uh whether
it uh it's like uh whether it's a strict
ethical vegan or carnivore and they'll
they'll have it at it and I have my own
take which I'm kind of I try to be a
moderator of good dialogue you know so
part of what I've gotten better at
what's is I think I've gotten better at
figuring out elor the balance of what
started with me just off the cuff
experiencing and just wandering around
I'm like a virtual Nomad going to places
asking people questions or making say
here's an opportunity for me make an
intellectual contribution and so I I
give an idea which I think is helpful to
the research out there I think a lot of
what I learned is that and what that
multivariate model that I have that is
optimizing continues to be optimized at
good but how that looks continues to
evolve and I struggle as issues come up
Elanor like controversies come up I'm
like should I ignore it is it a
distraction am i c getting myself caught
up in in a height
that is more alienating and
counterproductive where it should be
served other purposes or am I abating my
responsibility here should I be speaking
more uh directly here in terms of fs and
how do I do more most good and how do I
and I think people even when they're in
opposite poles of a view most people are
good and reasonable they just have
different paradigms so I try more to
Foster evidence to be the guide po post
and to have assume people are good at
heart and that if someone's bad at heart
you can't make them good even if that
was but I I really believe that that uh
in the geroscience community in
particular people really mean well and
they if someone is more optimistic about
the notion
of a time frame for longevity doing good
in the good doing good in the world and
being optimistic they believe that in
their heart of hearts and they're more
of a a futurist or transhumanist and
there other people who or more
conservative scientists say well we
haven't even extended a mouse mouse
lifespan more than you
know so we're talking about doing it
humans and how can we extrapolate and
what's responsible messaging will we not
be trusted if we over promise or are we
not trusted because we're not promising
enough because nobody believes us
because we're not refusing to make any
any sort of project forward projections
at all so the the biggest things that
have change changed and evolved is not
so much the content but my conception
and um but the other thing is I've
gotten far more sophisticated at chat
aging do one I preceded chat GPT so uh
you know I can have intellectual credit
for having my post pred that unless I'm
really the super top secret thing that's
even before CHF GPT but is smarter than
it um and hopefully wiser and without
with a minimal amount of
hallucinations um so but the other thing
is
the I I have an extremely collectic pool
from which I pull data so it it's not
like a simple PubMed search can do it a
PubMed search can be far more
comprehensive uh but it still at the
same time miss the my broad eclectic
passion interest that make things fun
and interest um and it could be oh those
literatures could be too broad or you
can have things like uh AG biology an
example of uh and highlights and aging
which are both fantastic Twitter feeds
all extremely high quality but if you
subscribe only to those and not to me I
think there are important things that
are also missed in terms of uh whether
it's even amongst the universe of high
quality things less to all the much
larger widespread it's like this is
crappy research you should probably know
it so because this is what people are
talking about tell the followers about
it tell the media about it uh bust the
hype or have a good discussion because
maybe you disagree but maybe they're
right or vice versa and maybe the truth
is somewhere in between and there needs
to be good discussion about it so I'm
I'm proud of being a unifier with um
that through all this time I
have succeeded and not alienating even
within the geroscience community for the
most part they're they kind of pseudo
exceptions but that people continue to
quote content and and use it as a
leverage point for them to be discussing
their point even if they're making
opposite points they're citing the
literature that I helped them
identify exactly um and that you made me
think of several follow-up questions and
now I'm thinking which one's best to ask
um well firstly I think what makes your
Twitter stand out from just like gu B is
you also share videos and occasionally I
see that if you've shared one of my
videos it's not just the like standard
YouTube link It's like got a screenshot
or somewhere in the video suggesting
that you you do actually watch it which
is my second point was um when it comes
to the the Articles you share on Twitter
have you how much have you read or are
these things that you share and you
maybe read the abstract or like how in
detail do you get the chance to actually
read
umount if you do the math and you add up
the seconds and you take an average
reading rate it would be impossible to
do a you know there are different
formats of fre there's skim study and
scan so
I I for people who've taken speed
reading classes uh you can sort of
adjust your rate and there's some signs
to it I mean some of it is a little bit
gimmicky but some of can work to a
degree in terms of eye movement for
speed reading but even even at a fast
clip you you can't go through it all so
the level of which I go for reading is
um what I basically use this the similar
sort of Paradigm that uh Einstein thinks
about a good theory a good theory I try
to have an optimization function for the
content I read and I optimize it with
two Targets one target is for interest
for the audience and another Target is
interest for myself if something's
interesting for the
audience um unless I think it's harmful
if I think it's Miss it's appropriate to
the mission and helpful even if it's
it's like really you know like a lot of
the media the media pieces okay it's
like that a lot of that's just that's
not a detailed read on the other hand uh
if you have you know new research coming
out of the like a a major major lab 100
Labs maybe that they have higher quality
work and uh they're more relevant pieces
to translation I tend to do more study
read so if it's if it's applicable to
something something that's actionable to
my own my own life uh or it's anything
related to health span longevity or it's
just more interesting to me or if I feel
that reading more deeply lends itself to
something I'm making a decision whether
or not to post it those things all are
variables it's very much I see myself as
a sort of curator I'm hard to reproduce
because there's a lot of art to it and
there's a lot of art to how deeply I
read you know I I can read papers
extremely efficiently for the level
needed to answer the question I want to
but others so it all depends on on what
on the paper I guess so I can't give you
an algorithm you know because chat GPT
just can't be replicated you know you
would have to literally capture my
Lifetime by that that bot and every
aspect of it every variable the mo the
molecules in my brain and then then they
could kind of use that as a mod model to
create one but um yeah that's that's my
that that's the method to my
madness yeah I see and obviously like
now you've been on Twitter over 10 years
am I right with that over 10 years no
that's something I'm very proud of that
I've been only on on Twitter since you
can fact check me on this now but I want
to say just since uh since two since
about 2020 so only about three years or
oh wow okay wow and what's what I find
amazing is when I went down to Twitter I
remember when I had my first follower I
was like I was really excited and then
when I got 10 I was like Wow there are
10 people because the first people that
followed me tended to be people who are
had a lot of followers it's like at the
uh at the time to degree now but at the
time it's like the only people that
followed me with a few exceptions here
there are people who were like were
really really people I respected a lot
and had really knew their stuff they had
labs they were very sophisticated they
were thought leaders and things like
that so I was very proud that I started
with zero followers none on Twitter and
most people come to Twitter who have who
uh develop a following and certainly
Following over some period of of of time
that's relatively quickly you know they
have a podcast they have a practice they
have something that they have a book
they have a Blog they have something
where people know about them this is a
complete stranger doesn't show his face
and all that stranger does is one
produce something that might be useful
like publish something interesting that
that just just it's interesting out
there and just picked it or two from
time to time makes a comment that's like
oh this person who posted they're not an
idiot or like oh that that's interesting
huh oh maybe I should follow this person
so just by virtue of that and the other
thing I'm part of is that that for my my
my my followers which is uh you know
more than 10K now in just a few years
and you have to look up the number but
that the the F the followers I I have
without resorting to any big gimmicks or
any big hype so you asked about you know
pictures and things like that that was
one of your questions so I have learned
along the way you know there's some such
things thing like AB testing where you
you try things one way you try things
another way and you see what Garners
more followers and for me being an
natural optimizer I sort of can't help I
help myself it's like oh well this
reaches more people but it's not just
optimization for optimization sakes it's
part of my core values all those
variables Elanor make me want to
optimize but I figure if I make if I
have the desire to make an
impact then the more people I reach the
more impact I can make so now I'm
slowing myself down Elanor to answer
your question so so if I find that
something seems to raise uh more
awareness in a responsible way that's
the key variable in a responsible way
responsible if I can do that in a
responsible way that I would could
pursue that so I noticed people like you
know pictures and things like that I'm
like so why not you know but like I I
could be I mean can I rule out will I
ever be one of those people that's like
one of those things like
you know this is crazy this is crazy or
like like hi like and I mean like I I
hope you don't use those images against
me my God you have editing power so you
use your P you know like the spider I'm
a big geek like I love quoting like geek
geek geek uh nerdy science but like with
great great Powers comes great
responsibility like from Spider-Man you
know what I mean like like it's it's so
true like you have a lot of
responsibility to wield in your
communication but you wield it very
responsibly and that's my point I try to
do so responsibly too one of the things
that really is upsetting to me on
Twitter and maybe a little bit of
Twitter burnout might be a little bit of
this too like like ah you know I'm I'm
doing some good here but oh there's so
much hype out there so I I don't I
although I I I try to be cognizant of
reaching an audience like I should be as
being responsible to the audience as
being able to reach people who might
benefit I try to do so not in this this
crazy hepful way and in fact that was
one of the reasons I created my channel
Elanor it was like the the degree to
which I saw social media and I didn't
follow it too much and I thought if I
get a channel maybe I could follow Jos
scientists and I could pick up these
little comments that don't make their
way to the Publications because I I want
to dig deeper because at the time I was
doing detailed reads method sections and
everything to the deepest geroscience in
the areas I read like reading covered to
like I my my PhD gave me a very strong
so I consider myself a geros scientist
in the sense that I my my knowledge base
is the is is sufficient in my being a
part of this the space that's different
than having a lab and anybody that has a
lab in an area will run circles around
me in terms of the specific methods for
okay like let's say NAD biology or you
know like okay this I'll construct this
experiment this way that but in terms of
being able to be a geros scientist in
the sense of being a thought leader and
having novel ideas to inject to it I
like to have an opportunity to create a
space where people can talk about the
science and not get caught up in hype
and a lot of terrible conflicts of
interest but really can and can have
healthy debates without it being
mudslinging or being selective the
evidence presented but to have a real
Meeting of Minds with a positive
pro-science approach which is
you could be you could be wrong I could
be wrong we both could be wrong we both
could be right and probably somewhere in
between those and let's learn from each
other in a positive spirit and let's
believe we're both good human beings and
let's in a collegial way maybe sometimes
in a little bit feisty way and certainly
in a a mentally critical way say hey
wait this that that but let's let's be
amicable and be respectful and
colleagues and bring science forward and
and find and line things so we can
ultimately reach more patients and make
more positive impact in the world yes I
mean I'm happy to hear that from you I
mean I think I have a similar approach
to this channel um and I think yeah one
of my sort of more final questions for
you was now that I mean of the time this
video comes out um you've now refilled
your um refilled yourself um like how
does that change uh the future of your
Twitter page or how like what sort of
challenges do you think you're going to
face now or how do you see the next
couple of years for
you so um
I I described the moment before between
now and the re reveal when it's still
just called project 49 that nobody knows
about except you Elanor and just a just
a few others um it's it's um with some
excitement and in trepidation
simultaneously you learn as a as a as a
physician to have thick skin to a degree
I'm I'm a sensitive soul I I I I'm
always you know and so I I but I felt
like it would I would not be true to
myself or to others if I could not
manifest a potential that I don't know
where that it even might lead and also
follow my own belief in as much
transparency as as possible and to to
put that out there you know so I I I I I
don't know where that what that's going
to bring uh but I I'm hoping that by
being public that I can be able to have
more an impact in a more Global Way than
the very specific way that led me to the
whole thing that's barite Consulting
that I'm creating it's barite
consulting.com and uh so I'm creating
I'm building that behind the scenes and
it's not up yet um and um and I'm having
like
learning all about web
design so and I'm having oh your your
viewers should probably know if you are
curious uh I'm having aging do.com point
to it that's easier uh and healthspan
coaching.com also point to that uh so
that's the coaching and the Consulting
and but that opens up my being able to
do other things like potentially do
higher order level stuff that's a
assumes the audience already is a geros
scientist or is a longevity Enthusiast
who is sufficiently high in their
reading that we don't need to spell out
to them what the geroscience hypothesis
is they know the Hallmarks of Aging by
heart they're very comfortable with the
concept of longevity medicine that you
can just go deeper because a lot of
researchers they have an opportunity to
talk to colleagues in research
conferences but they only have a few
minutes to answer questions at the end
of their talk their talk focuses usually
very narrowly on their latest research
but not more globally philosophically on
such matters as the direction of our
field uh responsible and effective
messaging being effective to being able
to translate the basic science of
biology of Aging to patients all those
things are extremely important but to
what audiences do they have an extended
format where these things are are really
articulated they are a bit by some
science communicators but not so much to
like kind of a more sophisticated
audience that really already knows this
stuff um and yet it's much more depth in
a more broad big picture conceptual
questions for the field than can be done
in a typical conference so that's kind
of some of my thoughts about some areas
where I can uniquely contribute to the
field and ultimately that's what it's
all about I I want to be able to
accelerate this really cool biology
which I'm fascinated by it's own own
sake I think that we should heavily uh
fund the basic sciences and not take
away from the basic Sciences but only
add to it not remove it and give more to
translation but keep the basic science
expand its basic underpinning so we
understand the biology of Aging better
and then having an additional expansion
to help bring it to patients because
that's that's where the metal that's
where the pedal meets the road right the
it's what we really care about is having
people live longer lives Liv that are
healthier for people to have whether or
not you're transhumanist or like a
futurist type orientation like uh like
myself I'm kind of see myself as a
futurist that is has both feet planted
very firmly on the ground of
evidence-based medicine like a moderate
in that regard but I'm very hopeful
about what Humanity can accomplish so I
figure over my lifespan if I can do some
things now either on my own or as part
of a larger Enterprise I mean you you
you asked what you know what the future
brings I have no clue so whether I do
things as this kind of in alone thinker
or is part of another Enterprise or
perhaps both like right now I'm still
working part-time and I'm managing this
um but I'm very passionate and as you
can see from my all the degrees and
things I've I've done I've always been
just a high high moona type of person
and and the excitement for me is I
discovering what those next moon charts
will be yeah well I think uh you
definitely have had an impact in the
space already and we'll continue to do
so if not if anything you've helped my
own channel grow and I appreciate that
so much so I can only yeah wish you the
best of luck with what comes your way
next and yeah I hope we continue to to
keep in touch and yeah if there's
anything else you want to say then do so
but it's just been great to speak with
you today and to hear your background
and your motivation for what you do oh
uh thank you Elanor I I appreciate being
on what is like um you're it's really
unique the what you put out there I've
been I really like a lot of people come
on to shows Elanor and they're like oh
I'm your biggest fan blah blah blah and
you're like you don't know if they
really mean it but what's cool is I I
didn't know you and I was like putting
out your stuff because I was so excited
about it and for those that can uh this
is being recorded today on October 13
2023 again like I'm Elanor is one a tiny
number of people who knows who I
actually what who I actually am and what
I actually look like that kind of near
barsel David Sinclair I David barsi dude
um that I was extremely enthusiastic
about your content from the beginning
and I think you're making an
extraordinary difference and um the nice
thing about being you know I'm in a
season in my my life and career that I I
can work parttime and I have out of out
of choice I was at some point I was a
partner in a practi practice so now how
things work out they don't matter to
they don't matter for me from uh I'm not
I I don't need the like for it to work
for me for my personal success from a
career standpoint is what I'm trying to
say this is more like a passion project
so whatever comes out of it is is good
and the more more the marrier and people
who have ideas feel free to reach out to
me and uh thanks thanks again for having
me Elanor it was really will be one of
my life time memories being on the show
with you oh great I know I'm really glad
to hear it